okay so I'm gonna be talking about brand
recognition in real life photos and I
also wanted to show you how easy it is
it can be done in Python how few lines
of code you need to do some powerful
things so few words about me I am a
machine learning engineer in Samsung in
R&D in Warsaw and I'm also a founder of
organization called human to heart it's
similar organization as PI data but much
smaller and we talked about intersection
of humanities and Technology so my
project started in data science retreat
it's a course
freeman's course here in Berlin
and there's some assumption of this
course that you go there to become a
better data scientist and you start by
learning data science big data science
Fink's and then you from the half of the
course you start to do your own project
and I wanted to do something with social
media and with images so I decided for
Instagram can I ask you how many of you
use Facebook and Instagram only four
persons five and snapchat the same as
Instagram
this is shocking yeah because you know
Facebook is much more popular in general
but yeah you can see Instagram numbers
from the official website so it's
enormous numbers 300 millions of active
users monthly 330 billions of photos and
two and a half billion slides every day
so it's enormous scale but the most
interesting statistics is here in the
bottom it's about followers engagement
brand and followers engagement it's
about that you have some followers as a
brand and how many of those followers
are actually engaging this brand by
likes comments shares anything so how
many of them are actually active and you
see this huge difference between Twitter
Facebook and Instagram huge difference
so
Oh Instagram is for brands but of course
don't forget that Instagram is owned by
Facebook from a few years so one of the
problems you have in Instagram as a
brand is that it has a huge noise of
information so these are the pictures
when you will type
hashtag Nike and Instagram you will get
those images of course order also but
you also find get free followers some
panda images some random products images
Lego because when you want to be visible
on Instagram you just put every popular
hashtag and you're just everywhere
Instagram so another thing is that if
you would imagine that what Instagram
sees as a system so it sees your heart
attacks its it sees your comments and
texts but it doesn't know what's inside
the picture so from the perspective of
the system of the software this is
what's visible by the infrastructure and
that's why I wanted to do the to be more
conscious about what's in the in the in
the pictures so that that's why brand
recognition in real life photos and one
of things you could use it for is that
companies that are monitoring brands in
Internet are more and more popular
they're doing enormous amount of money
like this is a popular case if someone
just writes in the Twitter here I heard
Virgin Mobile and someone from Virgin
Mobile just tracks the internet scrapes
all the internet
text text data and they can respond by
you know giving some free tickets and
they get customer back but it's all
about text and with brand recognition
you could do the same with visual data
so you could for example spot some image
and of course to use to to solve the
problem with images the best thing you
can use is deep learning right now how
many of you used deep learning for some
problems okay all right some of you so
the problems
you can spot is that you need ridiculous
amount of data so you need hundreds of
thousands of data to train a network and
it's hard to train because it takes a
lot of time it's it can takes weeks
months to train your network without any
results and the good things is that it
has the best results in image
recognition problems and the best thing
is that it learns features itself so I
didn't know anything about normal image
recognition like you know a visual bag
of words looking for some particular
features like edges contrasts I didn't
know about it and I isn't had to because
deep learning learns everything itself
and in this type of problems you have
free approaches done mostly in academia
so the first approach is that when you
have your when your dataset is about a
few thousands per one sample so it's
okay you can just make more from this by
adding some noise by doing random crops
in this images so you can artificially
make more images and try to train your
own network another approach is that you
don't have so many photos and you can
try and use some one network so for
example Google's Network oxfords Network
there are lots of networks download and
use as VM on top of it or use the spread
train network and only trained last
layers which are responsible for the
classification problem and you use this
approach when the network was trained
for different problems so for example it
was a network trained for classifying
dogs and you're trying to find some
cancer tissue so you use this but when
the problem is similar you use this so
this is what I used and I will show you
some lines of codes so this is only one
line of code that will load powerful de
plane de planning network from and
downloaded from internet it's a V GDS
network from Oxford and it's only one
line of code and you have this powerful
machine
think you have to do when you have some
someone's Network used to also you
always have to prepare function like
this that will prepare format of the
image because this network was prepared
for particular formats so it has size of
224 pixels and it has red green blue in
particular order so you have to switch
everything so don't try to compile this
code with your eyes but it's only about
preparing the proper format of the data
and that's it and when you want to use
SVM it's not one line from scikit-learn
that's it so of course the problem is
that the brunt when you took a real
image not like you know I can zoom on
some particular logo type and just take
it photo but normal people just take
photo and the brand is a small part of
the image that's why you have to use
some technique for it and I used sliding
window so you just take small parts of
the image and you go through the image
and try every small part if the brunt is
there and I used it very because I
needed the speed because I wanted to use
it on a bigger scale and Instagram to
use it fast so normally you could use
hundreds of the windows what I want to
do to do it fast so I only have 16
windows of with one third of the
original width the blue one and nine
windows of with one second and also the
whole Instagram picture so I checked for
every Instagram image I checked
26 images and of course the the biggest
problem is the data set so I had to
collect the data set myself and to learn
the network I had to learn SVM I had to
learn it only on logo types so I have to
cut them from every Instagram image I
had so I spent money Wally I think about
7 hours just cropping it from the images
and this is what I collected so you see
I have 6 type of classes and those
classes are counterparts so I have Nike
and Adidas
it's Starbucks and Costa Coffee and
Heineken and calls back and you do those
counterparts because if you train it
only and for example Adidas shoes
probably it will see every shoe as an
Adidas shoe so you have to differentiate
it and of course you have those six
classes but you don't want your network
to classify everything as a brand
because not everything this world is
brand so we have to have this random
class and to random class you could just
random things from stuff from the
Instagram so I told you the speed was
the very important thing for me
so the first network I tried gave me two
seconds per one image one single image
then I tried this network from Oxford I
recommend it to you if you would use
some deep learning because it's very
fast and very efficient vgg has network
and it gave me one second per image then
I try to optimize some code because I
used someone's code and tried to change
it and it gave me 200 millisecond and
then I used copy framework because I
started using lasagne and then I
switched to cover which is really hard
to configure it takes a day to configure
cover on your machine but then it gave
me only 20 minute seconds per image so
it's very fast so why do you need the
neural network here the only goal is to
take your Instagram image and image is a
data structure right it's a it's a 224
with 224 hight image and 3 channels red
green blue
so it's this amount of numbers and you
want to have and every point it's a
feature so it's a really huge amount of
features to your model especially that
you have only few hundreds of data
points so you want to make it make it
smaller and that's why you use the
network and by forwarding your image
fruit and network you get a really great
representation of this image much
smaller because it's only 499 95 96
numbers
so it's much smaller data that is
describing your image and to do it
another piece that I wanted to show you
but don't try to another time don't try
to compare compiled it by your eyes it's
only to show you the single steps you
only prepare your image so the first
code I was showing you to prepare the
format so to crop it to change the RGB
you add it to a batch because usually
those frameworks are working in batches
so you don't put one image but for
example ten images so you prepare a
batch and then here the most important
so here you put the data inside the
network and here when you have the batch
ready batch of ten I have a bunch of ten
you just type forward it's a function
forward it's ready and you get
representation of your image and this is
deep learning this is it and that's how
you prepare your training set very easy
and then how do you use as VM you just
put your data from which you got from
neural network to the classifier from
SVM and that's it this is the whole
pipeline another thing to keep in mind
is that in this kind of problems your
training set and testing set is
different because training pictures are
zoomed in logos and as a testing set
that you want to get some numbers as
results you twist test it on full images
so you have to prepare it separately so
this is my first pipeline so you're
getting features from networks you get
those four thousand long vectors you put
them to SVM as features and you use the
sliding window to check every place for
a brand and this very simple were
workflow and maybe few lines of code
more than I showed gave me this kind of
results so you see how powerful those
algorithms are and the most important
code is here and it's the
like I think it's them only code that
use some something more than just
changing the diet data from one column
to other column so you just here you're
just putting the getting the one image
and getting the windows wait 26 windows
from the image and putting inside the
network so here you just get
representation of those windows from
sliding windows you just put them to SVM
and as VM gives prediction for every
window
the default class for you is random and
then here you just check which of the
class has the highest probability and
you set it as the best class and this is
it
so now thinks how you can improve your
results so my network in the beginning
for example learned that every mmm green
thing is a Heineken because I don't know
why but on Instagram Carlsberg appear
often as a cans and Heineken has bottles
so every green color like this was
Heineken every cafeteria were Starbucks
because I don't know why but Kosta
coffee was often outside of cafeteria
and Starbucks was inside cafeteria so I
had to add cafeteria photos and of
course shoes like this also
adidas uses much more on Instagram there
are much more other clothes than shoes
inari does and when you check nike
hashtag it will be mainly shoes I don't
know why so I just put another some some
part of pictures with shoes but not
without brand and this improved only
adding some pictures like this improved
my results for a precision for 2%
another thing is that you have this
network it's it's not the network I used
but you know it's the presentation of
how networks looks like and you use it
for taking representation of images so
you could I was taking it from here but
you can also take it from here from here
you
can you can get output from any layer
you want so I was also testing with
different layers and it gave me another
3 percent result and how you do it
you just in this line you were just
switching the layer you're getting
output from so another no almost no code
to check it
another thing is probability cutoff so
you can adjust confidence the system has
to have to classify the image so when
you want your network to be really
precise to be confident that this is for
example Nike you can just change it that
if it's not confident for 90 percent you
are not taking its prediction so if it's
confidence for 90 percent you just say
it's a random glass if it's confident
more than 92 percent you take the
prediction and you see another
improvement is results and you know what
you have to do in code only you have
when you had this classifier image
function you just add this so yet you
just add some number and you add it to
if so if it's more than 92 and that's it
this is adjusting probability gutter so
having this first version of all the
pipeline I could use it against some
data and buy this to classify more data
so I get some I got like thousands of
images classified by my my my pipeline
and then again manually I was just
checking if here it was good if he was
not good just taking false positives and
false negatives and just to take more
examples for every class so I just
increased amount of examples by 500 per
class which was not know no longer 300
per one class but 800 per one plus so
much more data and you see it much more
data is the best thing you can get for
your results because it was plus 4 + + +
6 + + 3 percent more in results hmm
another thing is data commentation so
when you just don't have any source of
additional images and you want to
artificially make more so you can for
example the more of the pictures do you
look some different you can add some
noise or you can just crop the images in
random places and this gave me plus two
and plus three percent and I'll have to
do how to do it with Python you just
resize the images and you just take the
crop I just took crop in every corner so
upper left corner upper right corner and
so on and this code makes my data set
four times bigger another thing which I
found in papers mainly is the small
trick that you should just add
normalization here so you just normalize
the data you take from here and you see
the huge increase here and not another
time the code you take pre-processing
from a psychic learn only one line of
code to do it so it was my final form of
my pipeline and now when I was using it
against some some Instagram hashtag so I
for example type coffee and I was
looking for Starbucks coffees and asking
my classifier to classify me only
Starbucks coffee it would give me give
me this results it was first Razzles
classified my my my classifier so you
see it was it failed only one time here
classifying some coffee cup at Starbucks
but rest of them for example when you
look here the Starbucks logo is here and
it was recognized somehow so these are
my final results this is the overall
results for 6 class but it doesn't mean
much because you see how different is it
for different brands and you can imagine
why because adidas logo is only 3
stripes and you have for example I see
someone have there
t-shirt with white stripes and this
white stripes would be recognized as a
DDoS for example and when someone is a
when somewhere is a swoosh like Nike
logo type it could be recognized as Nike
and brands like Heineken occurred and
Carlsberg are much more complicated much
more complex so they are much more easy
to recognize by classifier so if you
would like to use usage for example
commercially it depends from the brand
some brands can use it some not and here
you can see some top examples so for
example here you see a classical Nike
it's a Nike logo here here you see how
Nike can have a different form from
different perspective because we can
imagine that this Nike but now it's more
like an L sign you know it doesn't look
like Nike and it should be recognized
every bottle of course were recognized
as a beer because I had much many many
beer bottles in my dataset this thing it
looks like a Starbucks logo but it's not
and of course because machine learning
is about patterns it's not recognized as
a Starbucks logo but some people could
confuse it this again looks like Nike
and we know that it's some something
about Nike brand but it's not recognized
as Nike
this is classic adidas stripes this is
Heineken because it's green and this is
interesting because I found that
pictures like this are recognized as
Carlsberg maybe you know why yeah
because cows Berg has a label words word
Carlsberg in its logo and everywhere and
it begins from cow and that's where I
Carl was always Carlsberg ok so that's
it that's that's how you can you can
make deep learning yourself it's very
easy so if you have some questions you
would you like to use it for your
problems just I'm working waiting for
some questions thank you very much
thank you very much thank you excuse me
yeah no I resized them so I resize them
to 224 that one one side of the picture
has to have to have 2022 hundred
twenty-four because you can get not
squares you can get rectangles and then
when you get a rectangle and one of the
side has 224 pixels you crop the center
of it to have a square okay any more
questions
yeah but to learn the position of the
logo so you want to train a classifier
to localize logo inside the picture
right now because it's it's interesting
if I understand it correctly because I
used the sliding window approach which
is very naive and think which is better
and is used right now is to so-called
regional proposal and you have a network
that is trying to propose your region
and you don't check nightly everywhere
some other question
okay let's think okay thank you very
much